this is by far the biggest movie I've  ever been a part of and it's just  massively scalable all idea was done  Mo's directing it and that was why I  wanted to do it wanted to see you  download direct on this scale you know  for anybody who saw the Beijing Olympics  or the extremes what he can do in a live  event imagine that kind of choreography  where's a thousand people in full battle  armor defending a wall torical Spanish  we hold on panel once you've done all  the hard work of shooting sup they back  use it just makes sense that you want to  marry the biggest movie with the biggest  format and when I thought on I'm acting  was like it was just it was overwhelming  and unlike any movie going experience  I've had it spectacular I can't compare  it to anything because there's nothing  like it  ah master screen